- What do you think of my makeup?
- Good.
- Good?
Did you do a good job?
What part did you do?
Yeah?
What else did you do?
My lipstick?
Wyatt did my lipstick.
(cheery music)
^Hey guys, I'm Hannah, the world's OK-est mom
and welcome to my bathroom.
If you're a busy parent like me, you know that mornings
with kids are the most hectic time of day.
I'm not paying attention to what I'm wearing or
how I even look as long as my kids have pants,
we're good to go.
One thing I've heard is that if you want to try
something but you don't have the time for it,
outsource it.
^So per your suggestions, I'm gonna have my two kids
^do my makeup for a week.
My six year old and my three year old boys
are going to do my makeup for a week.
I think this is gonna be a disaster
but this is what you guys wanted and best case scenario,
you know, they enjoy themselves and I learn
a couple makeup tips.
So wish me luck.
^I have a question.
^- What?
^- Do you want to do my makeup today?
- Yeah.
- Okay.
Are you gonna do it?
- Yeah.
- My kids' relationship with makeup thus far
is kind of just this mysterious thing mom has
in her purse that you're not allowed to touch
so you really want to touch it and like,
make a huge mess of it.
Like gum.
I can't even tell you how many times Wyatt has taken my
Colourpop liquid matte lipstick and put it on himself
and then lost the tube.
They're probably under a random piece of furniture
just like slowly staining everything because
if anybody owns that you know how much it gets
all over everything and it does not come off.
I didn't really give my kids any guidelines,
I just kind of spread it out like a big smorgasbord
but I realized very quickly that that was not
the way I should have approached things
because all they did was take their makeup brushes
and mix every single makeup that was out there
together and just pile it all over my face.
It's like when you're a little kid in a restaurant
and you have a fountain drink cup and you decide
to get a little bit of every flavor because
it seems like a cool idea but it actually tastes
really bad.
That's basically how the first day went.
^Okay so this is me ready for the day.
That's concealer.
And they did my eyebrows and mascara and eyeshadow
and blush.
Didn't really blend my concealer and
my lips.
You guys happy with your work?
- Yeah.
- It's really funny because I didn't give anyone
a heads up on this experiment but the second I walked
into work, everyone was like,
Do you like my makeup?
- Looks like someone special put it on you.
Your children?
Your sons?
- Everybody knows.
Can you guess who did the lipstick?
- Wyatt.
- Yeah.
^We are trying a makeup look today that is called
"high school dance".
That's what the boys picked.
I'm hoping that when they're done I'm gonna look
ready for homecoming.
I have my coffee, oh you're cool,
and a whole spread of makeup out and ready
for them to use.
So are you guys ready to do it?
- Yes!
- Yay!
- We decided that I was gonna pull up a list of
different makeup looks and they'd get to choose one.
I'd pull up an image of what it looked like and then
show them the brush and the shade they would use
to achieve that and then they took that
and ran with it.
And it went a lot smoother as far as not ruining
all the makeup I'd just bought but they're not,
they're just not good at doing makeup?
This was a look with a lot of heavy eyeshadow,
highlighter, lots of blush, pretty lips
but they were doing it at like, 8:30 in the morning
so it looked very ridiculous.
^This is my homecoming look!
This went a lot worse than I thought it would.
I don't wanna leave the house.
Really did not think it could look this bad but
here we are.
Get your pants on, okay.
Go get your pants on.
^Today we're gonna do a natural look because I feel
like less makeup is better.
Do you know how to do a natural look?
- Yes.
- I chose a natural makeup look because there is
only so much you can mess up with nude eyeshadow
and it really don't show.
Wow.
So I just needed a little break from the intensity
and also my skin needed a break.
I was getting very irritated eyes and I figured
this would give them a chance to adjust.
Mmm!
Thank you, you did a good job.
^Here's my completed natural look.
^The lips are a little bare, like the corners
were not completely done.
I don't know if Wyatt was going for a 20's flapper look
but the eyeshadow colors are pretty good.
I really think the natural look is the best look so far
because there was less for them to mess up.
I did ask Matt how he thought the makeup looked.
^- You look beautiful.
^Just gorgeous.
- And he could not tell the difference between
the way I do my makeup and the way the kids
did my makeup which, I think says something about
my makeup abilities.
^So I think we're gonna do a smokey eye.
^- Yes!
And lipstick.
- And lipstick.
Are you guys getting better at this?
- Yes!
- Yeah.
I don't know about that.
I don't know what it is with kids instincts,
they just want the darkest most ugh,
noticeable thing, they were just itching
to use the dark colors.
- First I'm gonna put this makeup on my mom.
- And they were dying to use my eyeliner.
There were some things that I just didn't
have them use one of which was my eyeliner pen
because I didn't want to lose an eye.
I didn't want that in a two year old's hands anywhere
near my face.
Oh, ow ow ow.
Oh my god.
So I caved this time and I let them use the eyeliner.
So Jackson is in charge of doing the eyeliner
and I totally understand what happened with him.
^Jackson started doing the eyeliner and was kind of
^of those things like,
I can relate when you're doing your winged eyeliner
and you get a part wrong and you end up just making
it thicker and thicker and thicker until it's covering
your entire eye, that's kind of what happened here.
It happens to grown women, I can't fault him for it.
It was a solid effort.
I look like I slept in my makeup.
Oh my god, I do not want to go out like this.
Can I just wear my sunglasses all day?
- Might be a little bit of a cop out if you agreed
for them to do your makeup all week.
- This day got a lot more reactions than the first
day I had gone to work with the makeup.
- Why are you wearing, oh.
- I walked out to meet Nick to go to lunch
and his immediate reaction was like,
^- Where are you going?
^You're not going to lunch looking like that.
- [Hannah] Yes we are!
- Why?!
I can't.
Cannot.
^- I wanna do rock and roll!
^- You want to do rock and roll high school?
They kept asking to do rock and roll high school makeup
because they're obsessed with The Ramones?
What is that?
- A song!
- [Hannah] It's a song?
Wanna do a makeup look based on rock and roll high school?
- Yes.
- Kay.
We'll see how that turns out.
It's like, you know when kids throw out arbitrary
phrases for stuff where they're like
"I want Spider-Man waffles" and I'm like we don't
have, what constitutes a Spider-Man waffle?
I don't know if these are meant to be second eyebrows
or eyeliner but they're there.
You can't really see how much eyeshadow is
dusted under here and I'm afraid to touch it
because I feel like it's all gonna smear
but this was the first day that they started actually
asking me "where does this go?"
"Where do I put this?"
"How do I blend it?"
and they were super into learning the intricacies
of doing makeup.
Wyatt will even take a little makeup,
like a little eyeshadow on the brush
and hold it up and be like
(blowing)
and then put it on me.
It was so funny to see them do it.
^I don't know, if I'm looking like this everywhere
^you can't really tell but also my face overall looks
a lot pinker than the rest of my body.
But if I go like this, if I walk around like this all day
no one will notice.
^Today is glitter day.
^- Yeah.
^- Okay.
- Princess.
- Alright, lets do it.
They had also been eyeing the sparkle eyeshadows
for a very long time and the highlighter that I bought.
They did a My Little Pony glitter princess highlighter
all over my entire face makeup look.
Look at that brush.
This brush is a glitter forest.
^I don't know if you can tell, there's glitter everywhere
^and Wyatt kind of painted
the sides of my face
and today is the day I have to go grocery shopping.
- Yay!
- I love grocery shopping.
It's like my happy place, my special time
and I really didn't want to go in this makeup.
That is some shiny all over my face.
Even above my mouth.
Alright, here goes nothing.
We're going in.
I didn't want to risk not being able to go back
to that Trader Joe's out of embarrassment and I didn't
want to risk being known as the woman with
the weird makeup.
This is so embarrassing.
Every time I blink there's a glitter puff that flies off.
The cashier was super nice to me.
I know they were probably like holding in their
laughter the entire time but they were very kind
and I got through the entire shopping experience
unscathed for the most part.
^So today we're doing fancy makeup.
^I don't quite know what that means but Wyatt's
gonna take the lead.
Apparently what it means is blue and green eyeshadow
to match my hair.
Which is, it's cute in theory but they were trying
to do some under eye shadow that ended up just
kind of circling the bottom and making me look like I
had been punched in both eyes and then Jackson
who had been practicing this whole week was like
"I want to do your lipstick!"
and he whips out my LipSense.
The second he pulled out the wand, I had flashes of
the Joker makeup stuck on my face.
He actually did a really good job and I'm super
super grateful.
^I guess fancy makeup means blues and greens and very
very bright red lipstick.
I'm gonna add a little mascara to this.
I just, I can't have them do it because
there is the,
- [Wyatt] I do mascara.
- You can help me.
Overall from here down I looked okay and then
from here up I looked like I'd gotten in
a severe fist fight.
So I got to work that day and really of all the days
this day had the most at stake because there was
a meeting with my team and some clients calling
in on video chat.
So I told myself it's on video,
they're not gonna be able to see very well.
It's gonna be blurry.
But then my coworker walked in and all that immediately
went down the drain.
^- We have clients at this meeting.
^It looks like you got punched in the eye.
- [Hannah] They're not gonna see because it's on video.
- No.
You need to take that off.
- I have a solution for this.
So I probably looked super hungover but after
seven days of this experiment I'd much rather
look hungover than like a crazy makeup lady.
So what did I learn from this seven days
of complete madness?
Well first I learned that I could afford to spend
^a little more time on my makeup in the morning.
There's a lot of stuff that I could try and it really
doesn't take that long to do something fun and unique
with makeup and actually put a little bit of effort into it
and it's fun!
I want to do more of it and I want to try more.
Second I learned that my kids, bless their hearts,
^they think I'm beautiful no matter what.
Through this whole experiment every day no matter
how horrendous my makeup looked they would be
constantly encouraging me, constantly telling me
how beautiful I am and how awesome I am and how
great I looked.
- Pretty mom.
- You're so pretty you look like mermaid.
- It was so nice to just see that what's on the surface
is not what they see, they just genuinely love me a lot
and I love them a lot.
They're happy with me no matter how I look.
^And third, I realized that my kids likely will
^never be makeup artists, not in the near future,
not ever.
Probably not even artists but you know,
that's okay.
Go be an athlete, go be a scientist, go be an engineer,
pay for my nice nursing home, love you, thanks,
remember your mom.
Just don't do my makeup or anyone else's.
Alright guys, I did it.
Go easy on me because I'm still a beginner but I did it.
Anyway that's all I've got for today.
I'm Hannah and I learned a lot in this experiment
but I've got to know, have you guys ever let your kids
do your makeup?
Or are you gonna let your kids do your makeup because
if so, leave it in the comments,
I really wanna know that I'm not alone.
And if you really want to make my day,
^text me a picture of how it looks.
^This is a real number and I read every single one
^and I would love to see what your kids come up with
^because hopefully it's better than what my kids did.
Now if you'll excuse me, I have to get out of the house
because I have makeup on today and I need
somebody to see it even if it's just
my grocery store cashier.
Till next time!
(cheery music)
^Thank god there's a mouth hole on this.